what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to man
attempts brainwashing technique on women
and fails
miserably um so this channel is actually
called the toxic
dating coach and it's interesting
because he does content on like the dark
side of attraction
um i don't know i'm always just so
interested in that kind of stuff because
it's really interesting to hear like
the psychological tricks people use in
dating but before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification
bell um that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos
while you're at it go follow my
instagram i also accept video requests
on instagram so if you have a video you
want to see me react to send it to me on
instagram
all right guys this is alex you're talk
to dating coach and today we're going to
be talking about
sorry i'm not threatening you guys with
this stick
hear that sound um we're going to be
teaching you guys um
the most toxic and i mean toxic i mean
that goes beyond the toxic dating coach
strategies that men use to brainwash
women
women use it as on men as well okay and
even it even happens in the court system
um but we're going to show you what this
is through a video from the show
love is blind and the strategy that they
use is called gas lighting now
just like anything in life you know how
when you used to say i'll never get old
and then you look yourself in the mirror
and you're getting old
or i'll never be the one that gets i'll
never get dumped and then you get dumped
like we we we sort of think that we're
we are
in a we are an exception to the rule so
we don't think we will ever meet a
narcissist we don't think we will never
meet
somebody who's gaslighting you until you
meet them
and when you meet them you don't even
know what you're looking at it's like
being part of a cult
nobody knows they're in a call until
somebody tell until they
until they think back until we then they
they reflect a few weeks
months or even years later and realize
you're wearing a call
you know good manipulators you don't
know you're being manipulated until you
look back into it a few years later
okay or maybe a few weeks or months so
and this guys do this on a small level
especially when they're cheating on you
um and and they're trying to
manipulate you in one way or another
they use the strategy so to all of my
alexians to all my toxic gang members i
want you guys to be immune
of this phenomenon by watching this
video or
um close the channel if you don't watch
this whole video you don't want me to do
that okay
um so that the lord blesses you and you
could bless his son that's right ladies
and gentlemen
if the lord i'm okay with that
all right so with that being said
sometimes his intros are kind of long so
i skipped that let's begin this video
we're going to watch two different
videos this is going to be really
interesting
so this guy um proposed to her
all right and they're about to get
married they're engaged
but he didn't tell her that he was a
bisexual dude
okay um there's some issues behind that
obviously
right but um so he's so she's
confronting him why didn't you tell me
you were bisexual and rather than him
apologize
this is how he applied black gas
lighting let's watch
no feelings about i'm okay with or
without this situation i am okay
oh you know what i ain't got time for
this because you having a bad attitude
he's pretty much he's pretty much
invalidating her feelings obviously if
somebody told you they were if a guy
told you he was bisexual
and he didn't admit to it um she would
obviously should obviously understand
that it's his fault
but what he is doing is pretty much
saying yeah go ahead you know what i'm
gonna let you vent
i'ma let you have your moment in other
words he said okay you're the one that's
angry
you're the one that's that's out of
control i'm gonna be the mature one
and let you be the one that's that's
acting dumb
you see before you confront these people
you gotta be very rational with them
because they're very slick
and after this video after this one
we're gonna watch a video that
that explains how to identify
narcissists i mean i'm i'm
um gaslighting so that you guys can
avoid it but generally speaking they're
very slick because if you're a nice
person
if you're somebody that that is easy to
guilt trip if you're somebody that has
the
ib gosh that's me i'm so easy i feel
guilty really easily
[ __ ] you know that ibandito puerto rican
say abendito
when when they feel bad you know that
all [ __ ] right you get you feel bad
if you're somebody that's an empath and
easily feels bad you're going to fall
for this
you're going to fall for this because
you're going to want to connect with
them
you like the person right you you want
to connect with them your oxytocin makes
you
makes you forget about all the negative
things they did because connecting with
them feels good so what he is trying to
do now he's trying to invalidate how she
feels by saying you're the one that's
overreacting
in the hopes that she sort of buys it
buys into it
but you know this only works best was
the crazy thing is is that
this works best when one the other
person when the person is
isn't in is in is emotional now how did
how do you get the person to become
emotional
one hopefully there's a crisis going on
in their lives
that that has that weakens them so that
they can start believing your reality
like they feel mentally weak because of
stress
that's that seems to happen or two they
like you so much
sometimes that that's the truth
sometimes they like you so much and
depend on you emotionally so much
that they'll rat they'd rather get lied
to them not be without you
so let's see what she does basically
you're taking off your ring because i'm
being honest with you you'd rather a man
lie to you about
who he's been with or his past like
that's insane
i don't i don't need that so he's pretty
much saying why are you mad at me for
telling you the truth
you know like you're just you're just
mad because i told you the truth what
she's mad about is the fact that he told
her the truth
after one within after they had
he told them he told her the truth when
there was one month
left before they got married which is
kind of [ __ ] up
take the energy in my life have you gone
by
see what she's doing what she's doing is
that she's believing her own eyes
you got to trust what you're looking at
whenever you're being ghastly that
happened to you i will say that's my
biggest
problem is a lot of times things will be
right in front of me
um and i always want to understand the
other point of view
but you know and then i'll second guess
myself i'll be like am i wrong
am i did i not like see what i saw to me
there was one girl who i was living i
was living in um in brooklyn
it was i'll be honest with you ladies
that was actually the the lowest point
that was actually the lowest point if
you want to see the lowest point in my
life
to just watch my videos from from jan
from february of 2019 you'll notice
you'll look at the videos you'll notice
i'm very skinny
i think that was like the lowest point
in my life to be quite honest with you
and in that moment um i was i was
learning how to draw
and i was living with this girl that i
moved into her apartment it wasn't her
apartment it was actually an apartment
that somebody had
and she was the last one living there so
i moved in you know what i'm saying it's
like she was also
paying somebody else right but because
she was the last one there she had
the rain over the place and that's okay
anyways
what happened was i was drawing and
sometimes some paint will fall on the
floor now mind you that that's the kind
of paint that you could clean
but she just started getting on me she
got she got so mad at one point where
she started crying she literally started
crying why because i was so messy and i
felt bad i was like
am i really that bad like am i really
that dirty like i'm not
i know i'm i know i'm not the the most
the most
neat person but to the point where she
cries right
and thinking back at it in that moment i
felt really bad but thinking back at it
she was gaslighting me
i could promise you she was gaslighting
me because there's no way you would cry
because somebody
left their they're [ __ ] shirt on the
floor
you know what i'm trying to say maybe
you'll get mad but not [ __ ] cry
i don't know my mom's been so frustrated
with us
and so i was gaslighted but
coincidentally in that moment my legs
i couldn't walk because i had a knee
injury and i was
really really really depressed because i
didn't know why i was injured
it got to the point where i would wake
up and i didn't even i didn't even want
to get out of bed i was i was that
depressed
so with that with the combination of me
being
down and her gaslighting me i believed
it for a moment
and i thought i was going crazy i was
like this [ __ ] is crying for this but
i guess you know what i'm saying like
it's always good to talk about it with
somebody whenever you find yourself in a
situation because
the only way to counter their attacks is
to believe in what you have to say
you have some serious issues for the
fact that you see
what she's pretty much bombarding her
she's on the offensive she's on the
offensive rather than
rather than saying i'm i'm not crazy i'm
not blah blah
i'm not the one that's crazy no she's on
the offensive you're going you're crazy
you're out of your mind she's on the
offensive you get what i'm trying to say
and so when somebody's gaslighting you
you got to believe in what you're saying
because they'll try to make you think
you're crazy
you have to believe what you're saying
you're gonna disrespect me because
i'm disrespectful you led me
he's mad that she
did she's mad that she's mad
that he didn't ex in other words
he's like why are you mad and she's like
you didn't tell me you were bisexual
from the beginning
you know what i'm trying to say which is
kind of logical but he's mad that she's
mad at that
yo narcissists
can't comprehend why either they can't
comprehend it or they know
but at the end they don't act stupid
like
they act when you confront them they act
like you don't know what the hell they
don't know what the hell you're talking
about like why are you mad at me like
it's
what are you talking about you're
overreacting you get around trying to
say and i'll make
that make you think you're going crazy
and if you let that happen you could
lose your sanity if you let that happen
long enough i don't have i think you're
going crazy
what they don't want you to do so is to
have some space so that you can think
rationally they don't want that
[ __ ] this is why i don't deal with
[ __ ] like you and i
see now his true coming out why because
she was on the
on the offensive oh i'm a [ __ ] now
you don't call me a [ __ ] in my face i
don't deal with women like you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you father
i like it because she's on the offensive
that's a strong-minded woman right there
she's
on the offensive she doesn't let him
she doesn't let him manipulate her
she can never be with that right
now let me show you what the only
problem is i've seen like women with her
demeanor don't tend to get married that
like fight like that
like guys don't like girls
that fight like that the other strategy
is right
whenever you encounter a narcissist let
me show you their other strategy
um with that being said let me let's put
this right here um
by the way people check out check out
our
um our course that's like natural
chemistry which is for single people you
could purchase it
okay so now let's watch um what gas
lighting is
three there are lots of things to look
out for but we're gonna go through three
of them today what's the first one
the first one is when somebody says to
you you're too sensitive
or you have no right to feel that way
when you do that you immediately tell
them that their emotional world
is invalid and you're
judging them for you have no right to
and if you do that long enough
that person will begin to doubt
everything that comes okay so this is
why i think the term narcissist
is overused i'm sorry i hate to be that
person
but some people shouldn't feel a certain
way
and what i mean is like don't everyone
has that friend that's overly emotional
and gets themselves worked up over
everything even the smallest things so
that's what i think of when she says
that because you always hear women
calling their ex narcissists and i don't
always think they are
but i'm going to keep listening i'm not
saying narcissists don't do that i'm
saying i don't think that's
that in itself is a tell-tale sign of
narcissism their mind and though
and though and and they'll depend on you
on the and you depend on the other
person to tell them what reality
really is i feel that way as though you
are judging jury
on their emotional state right okay so
what that does
is it makes a person literally doubt
their feeling and a feeling is a
spontaneous experience
so now it's almost like telling someone
you must be too
hot and they're perfectly comfortable or
telling someone they're hungry
when they're not yeah you know so this
is the emotional
when we do this emotionally it is and
that's pretty much how to turn to
people into becoming zombies and what
happens is that
a lot of people give up that kind of
power whenever they're like
we're going to speed her up whenever
they like somebody they give up that
kind of power
where those sort of give them the
benefit of the doubt when they start
doubting what they're doing
turned gas fighting because the person
was like i thought i was
that but you're telling me i don't get
to be angry about this
and then some people when i told it
enough they believe it right when people
are
given this situation being told you're
too sensitive you have no right to feel
this way
the best thing to do is to not engage at
that point because you can't win
no matter what you say this person if
anything by those statements has shown
that they're willing to emotionally
manipulate and abuse you
there's nowhere to go in that
conversation you gotta go
like and that's what she did don't you
notice that that's what she did right
he did that and as soon as she and as
soon as he did that
she pretty much pulled away
what the mistake that a lot of you
ladies do is that you guys stick
or your ego gets involved so much that
you need to win
you can't win you cannot win against a
narcissist
they're an expert at gaslighting you so
if they say that
maybe if anything say no that that's
that is in fact how i feel
and leave it at that but they're going
to keep pushing at you so you can just
let it go
and know the conversation ends there
instead of you getting into a
uh ongoing trust your instincts
if you're willing to ask yourself maybe
i'm wrong
it's good to do that in the beginning do
that
ask yourself that all right
but then if you're if you're noticing
that they're aggressive in terms of
letting you know
that you're wrong if you notice if you
sense an aggression behind that
they're trying to gaslight you but just
for measures at first ask yourself maybe
you're wrong
think about it and then observe if that
person is very aggressive to get you to
believe what they're trying to say
and if you're noticing that then they're
using their aggression
to change the way you think about the
situation
it's better off to pay attention how the
person is trying to convince you then
your
own thoughts in a way like if you know
what i'm saying it's like in a certain
aggression but you know what let's
i think she's gonna explain that a
little bit further right okay
the second is deflection believe it or
not deflection is a form of gaslighting
because you're talking about something
you might take the time and say we need
to talk about this issue
and sit the person down in a hope of
benefiting your relationship
and maybe you raise up something i don't
know about a lie or about something
financial in a relationship
and they deflect it to well you know
what now that you brought this up
remember two years ago when blah blah
blah blah and now
an issue you're bringing up that's very
relevant to here and now they now are
talking about something that happened
years ago or something that's unrelated
so it's pretty much changing the topic
right
like the guy with like the gay guy well
not the gay guy the bisexual
he was telling her she was telling him
why didn't you tell me
that that i was that you were bisexual
from the beginning and then he started
playing the victim
and saying that she that and pretty much
saying that she was victimizing him
that he can she can't accept the truth
you know he's living his truth
why you got to be so sensitive you know
it's pretty much deflecting and pretty
much saying that the reason you're
noticing this
is because you're flawed not because i
lied to you but when they deflect
they deflect to a situation that makes
you look bad and see what i would want
to do is say excuse me you're deflecting
and i'm guessing that's right they'll
say oh because that situation makes you
uncomfortable doesn't it and they'll
you see yeah that's pretty much i think
that's what he said too i think so and
now he says something along those lines
i think they're gonna tunnel
so when there is that look at that dog
trying to reflect
of deflection once again you can either
gently bring it back say
okay you know we can come back to that
absolutely think we should talk about
that if it's important to you
i really want to stick right now though
to the issue that we were originally
talking about
oh my god you know it's really hard to
talk about and then they might keep
going back and forth
if you have to rein them in more than
twice that conversation is done
you're gonna have to either find a
different forum for it i realize you may
never get to have that
pay much attention ladies and gentlemen
um i you could find
you could find her um listen her name is
um
what's was dr ramini just so that you
guys could find her on your own
conversation yeah managing expectations
of a reoccurring theme
when you are dealing with someone who's
interested especially gaslighting
especially
the third is it's so interesting being
so
i'm very like trusting and i don't know
i just believe when people say things to
me
but it's gotten me in trouble over the
years and it's really interesting
like almost being on the outside looking
in like on people that are just really
good liars and manipulators
the third example of gaslighting is that
never happened
now
when you get to that level that's that's
that's you're far gone
you're far gone if when you get to that
level like
that's that's deep right there that
that's [ __ ] deep
so to which you know most of us when
we're told that our first tendency
believe it or not is
maybe that didn't you know i'll always
say like i'll get a little older maybe i
didn't remember that
and there will be people the internet's
made this easier they'll go back over
old photos they'll dig up old emails and
they'll say
ah there it is and proud as punch
they'll trot that evidence
up to the narcissistic person and say
see
it was crazy that this this happened
with a few friends of mine in the past
like the friend who was who um back in
high school
had a buddy of mine back in like the
ninth grade who was always late
and i had to stop being friends with him
i have friends who were late like i said
but not like this guy
um i had to stop being friends with him
because he never admitted he was late
you could you could bring up the
situations even text messages
and he'll always find an excuse it was
like it was like it couldn't get it was
i mean honestly it was actually shocking
it was honestly shocking
he could never he cannot he could not
sense why people didn't like him and
people would around them would literally
be
grilling him with anger and this
[ __ ] would be
like like [ __ ] he'll be acting like
he's running down the field with
butterflies and
and [ __ ] twinkle berries and [ __ ]
like just like the whole world there's
nothing wrong in this world
and everyone just [ __ ] this everyone
around them just
hate him it's insane it's like
it's like it it's like it's it's a i'm
not gonna lie
like sometimes hanging out with him i
was just shocked by the level of
delusion that people [ __ ] face or
they'll deflect again
oh how nice would you like me to pull
out emails to show when you did this to
me then
that this and so it's very unsatisfying
i've always said that a surefire sign to
detect whether you're being gaslighted
in a relationship
is you get to the point where you feel
like you need to either a
record all your conversations but i can
tell you this right now if you play back
that according to the narcissist
they're not going to cop to it they're
going to either say you are such a petty
person
that you had to feel the need to to uh
to
record our conversation
it happened like that you can't win
they're they're they're just that far
gone you cannot win
you just can't you and they will get
very sort of morally high and mighty
but you're doing this to preserve your
sanity if you do make these recordings
they're really only for your sanity you
can say okay
i didn't i did say it this way i didn't
say the thing they said the thing about
narcissists is they'll always sleep like
a shadow of doubt
in your mind so you're not sure and if
anything that data might give you
more conviction to realize this person's
gaslighting you
and decide what your next step's going
to be another mistake people make when
they're in gas id relationships is they
write the wrong email
because see the gas lighter never
listens to you they're always deflecting
and
accusing you're not you're too sensitive
yeah if you encounter somebody like that
ladies
um a lot of times you just you can just
feel it you
you feel frustrated you start look for
the symptoms you know
you start feeling like your reality
isn't true
all right guys so if you guys enjoyed
this video don't forget to hit the like
button okay
i like him actually i think he's got
interesting content um
let me know in the comments if you guys
like me reacting to his videos because i
might do some more on the channel don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
bring that notification bell
and i will talk to you guys next time